herr professor zastrow ist das der
richtige schritt wenn ich selber schon
einmal corona hatte muss sich jetzt
nicht den quarantäne wenn ich auf
jemanden treffe ja das ist auf jeden
fall der richtige schritt denn das haben
wir von anfang an eigentlich alle ja
vermutet dass wir eine immunität haben
werden bei den meisten viruserkrankungen
haben wir eine lebenslange immunität und
würde das wird hier auch nicht anders
sein
man hat sich getraut weil es auch
unterschiedliche berichte gaben
insbesondere auch aus china
also ich finde das absolut richtig ich
gehe auch davon aus dass man eine
immunität hat das werden wir dann sehen
ob sie paar monate ist oder paar jahre
oder sogar lebenslang aber auf jeden
fall ist das natürlich gut für die
gesellschaft und zweitens denkt es auch
die zahl der tests die dann sinnloser
weise überflüssiger weise gemacht wird
also dass insgesamt eine gute
entscheidung vom rk ii
diese so zu empfiehlt und wenn dann doch
jemand symptome bekommen sollte
da kann er auch noch eine ganz andere
erkrankung haben aber dann macht man
eben dem test aber nicht von vornherein
erst mal wieder alle nach hause schicken
und auch die test machen und am ende
kommt gar nichts raus also mal ganz kurz
an einem praktischen beispiel der
politiker friedrich merz hatte sich ja
bereits mit corona infiziert ist dann
geheilt und ist jetzt trotzdem wieder in
häuslicher quarantäne weil er auf einen
menschen getroffen ist der jetzt positiv
getestet worden ist das ist dann ab
jetzt einfach ja eigene eigene
bestimmung ob man das machen möchte oder
nicht aber wenn ich weiter raus gehe
stelle ich eigentlich keine gefahr dar
genau so ist es er hat die erkrankung
einmal durchgemacht ist wieder gesund
also wird er auch ausreichend antikörper
haben dass er dadurch dass er kontakt
nochmal hatte zu einem
positiven corona menschen wird er kein
überträger mehr sein
also er ist mit sicherheit gar keine
gefahr deswegen auch keine charaktere
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren